[Music]
for Jason Aldean it was an unforgettably
emotional night at the 2018 Academy of
Country Music Awards first Aldean opened
the show with fellow artists in a
tribute to the victims of the deadly
mass Las Vegas shooting with respect and
love for the victims our friends family
and fans we celebrate the music tonight
the shooting was only six months earlier
and it was just a few blocks from where
the ACMs took place al Dean himself was
on stage that night I think it's
obviously a classy move on the part of
the ACMs to acknowledge and you know and
I'm glad to be a part of that it's tough
whenever it gets brought up it's still
tough you know and then al Dean closed
the ACM Awards by winning Entertainer of
the Year it's been a rough year and I
just want to say thanks to everybody
that reached out to us to my route 91
people you guys are in our hearts always
11
and we love Las Vegas Vegas strong baby
et spoke to him moments later backstage
oh you're shaking a little bit oh man
it's a it's been a crazy weekend here
and just you know a lot of stuff over
the last six months for us and you know
what a what a way to come back to Vegas
and crazy that's that's unreal
[Music]